Get your costumes and your beads ready, we're having a Mardi Gras party.
You will need: invitations, costumes, decorations,...
...music, food, drinks and a king cake.
Optional: Recordings of "The Mardi Gras Mambo" and "Carnival Time", Sazerac,...
...sangria and Ramos gin fizzes.
Step one: Send festive invitations to your guests...
...three to four weeks in advance.
Tell your guests that costumes, masks...
...and traditional Mardi Gras colors of purple, green and gold are a must.
Make sure your costume stands out...
...since you are the king or queen of the party.
Step two: Decorate your house New Orleans style.
Different colored beads, colorful masks,...
...decorative doubloons and balloons make great decorations.
Step three: Keep your guests moving...
...by playing upbeat New Orleans jazz throughout the night.
Don't forget to play "The Mardi Gras Mambo" and "Carnival Time."
Step four: jazz up the evening by serving your guests gumbo,...
...jambalaya, crawfish boil and dirty rice.
Step five: Toast your guests with classic Hurricane cocktails served in bright,...
...festive Hurricane glasses.
Sazerac, sangria, and Ramos gin fizz are also classic Mardi Gras cocktails.
Step six: Serve the famous king cake for dessert.
The person who gets the slice of the cake with the baby inside hosts next year's party.
Have fun!
Did you know?
The first official Mardi Gras parade was held in New Orleans on February 24th, 1857.